it'd be nice to be able to jump around
and kind of explore different little
sides of this but let me ask one sort of
romanticized question what to you is the
most beautiful aspect or idea of risk
instruction set or instruction sets for
this yet oh well I think that you know I
I'm you know I I was always attracted to
the idea of you know smallest beautiful
why is that the temptation in
engineering it's kind of easy to make
things more complicated it's harder to
come up with a it's more difficult
surprising that you come up with a
simple elegant solution and I think that
there's a bunch of small features of
risk in general that you know where you
can see this examples of keeping it
simpler makes it more elegant
specifically in risk five which you know
I'm I was kind of the mentor in the
program but it was really driven by
christos sama [ __ ] and two grad
students andrew Waterman Yin Sibley is
they hit upon this idea of having a
subset of instructions a nice simple
instructed subset instructions like
40-ish instructions that all software
the software status v can run just in
those 40 instructions and then they
provide optional features that could
accelerate the performance instructions
that if you needed them could be very
helpful but you don't need to have them
and that that's a new really a new idea
so risk five has right now maybe five
optional subsets that you can pull in
but the software runs without them if
you just want to build the just the core
forty instructions that's fine you can
do that so this is fantastic
educationally is you can explain
computers you only have to explain forty
instructions and not thousands of them
also if you invent some wild and crazy
new technology like you know biological
computing you'd like a nice simple
instruction set and you can risk 5e if
you implement those core instructions
you can run you know really interesting
programs on top of that so this idea of
a core set of instructions that the
software stack runs on and then optional
features that if you turn them on the
compilers where you use but you don't
have to I think is a powerful idea
what's happened in the past if for the
proprietary instruction sets is when
they add new instructions it becomes
required piece and so that all all
microprocessors in the future have to
use those instructions so it's kind of
like is for a lot of people as they get
older they gain weight right as that
weight and age are correlated and so you
can see these instruction sets get
getting bigger and bigger as they get
older so risk five you know let's you be
as slim as year as a teenager and you
only have to add these extra features if
you're really gonna use them rather than
every you have no choice you have to
keep growing with the instruction set I
don't know if the analogy holds out but
that's a beautiful notion that there's
it's almost like a nudge towards here's
the simple core that's the essential
yeah I think the surprising thing is
still if we if we brought back you know
the pioneers from the 1950s and showed
them the instruction set architectures
they'd understand it they that doesn't
look that different well you know I'm
surprised and it's if there's it maybe
something you know to talk about
philosophical things I mean there may be
something powerful about those you know
forty or fifty instructions that all you
need is these commands like these
instructions that we talked about and
that is sufficient to build to bring
upon you know artificial intelligence
and so it's a remarkable surprising to
me that is complicated Minoo
microprocessors where the line widths
are narrower than the wavelength of
light you know is this amazing
technologies at some fundamental level
the commands that software executes are
really pretty straightforward and
haven't changed that much in in decades
it's what a surprising outcome so
underlying all computation all Turing
machines all artificial intelligent
systems perhaps might be a very simple
instruction set
like like a risk five or it's yeah I
mean I that's kind of what I said I was
interested to see I had another more
senior faculty colleague and he he had
written something in Scientific American
in you know
his 25 years in the future in his turn
doubt about when I was a young professor
and he said yep I checked it and I was I
was interested see how that was going to
turn out for me and it's pretty held up
pretty well but yeah so there's there's
probably there's something I you know
there's there must be something
fundamental about those instructions
that were capable of creating you know
intelligence and from pretty primitive
operations and just doing them really
fast
you